everyone I'm David Griffin I have a
special guest me today Michael Dina
we're talking about one of the can call
this breakaway hits of last season from
the cwe this is a brick way to get what
yeah that's a big big shot for sure we
talked about cw's arrow season one and
we're also going to talk a little bit
about you know some of the news last
month from comic-con and also you know
talk about the trailer but we kind of
expect from season two but first we're
going to kind of go over season one a
little bit what we liked about it so
start with Mike you know be in here
joining us what was your some of your
favorite things from season one um you
know what first of all growing up I was
in a really green arrow fan you know
what i mean so going into the show
really to know what to expect I was a
big huge Smallville fan I mean
Smallville had its ups and downs like
halfway like in the middle tour of its
run and whatnot but it got better
towards the end so go into this show I
was a little like okay whatever I'll
take it for what it's worth but it
really surprised me right um you know
it's a CW show so I was afraid like
small but it would have a little bit of
Etsy delete cheese all over it be a
little soap opera kind of what not some
bubblegum every right but no it really
was good yeah I felt like it was
actually taking itself kind of seriously
yeah you know doing the character
justice it's a little Batman II I guess
you know failed this but um you know
what though but I think it works yeah I
think it's fun you know uh i just love
the formula the setup of everything i
like the constant flashbacks that works
for me a little bit of his backstory
like what happened on the island and
stuff like that and it's been really fun
rusty I was a little worried because I'd
like you know you've seen all of
Smallville I had not seen really much a
small but watch the finale part of it
the one part i did see was Superman you
know punching apocalypse a plan and I
was like that does it make sense but I
said okay so I was a little bit worried
coming to this because this guy hurts
him you told me some more stories from
small but he said I was very good in
beginning and then had some down turn
towards the middle where's the middle
rough so I was like let's see what this
is gonna be and I watched like wow this
is like Jason Bourne meets a little bit
of Batman it's a little bit uh you know
I mean he is a little bit darker for
schmidty's in the comic book I was fine
with it oh yeah he's a little different
i preferred i mean shouldn't say i would
prefer by i really would have liked to
seen the traditional ally just kind of
bit of a smartass or not but I mean this
is fun too though I like it yeah i mean
i was in situ i like that i think it has
a little bit of an advantage
on Superman not cuz it's Superman's
fault which is because they can do you
know special effects with guns and close
combat yes you're grounded my alley
right yeah man's cost more money how
does a different budget yeah I did a
good job but uh talk a little about the
the cast yeah supporting cast I think
it's uh I love the family dynamic I
really like you know he has a sister who
he calls speedy which is interesting
because the Roy Harper is in this
universe yeah is also speedy yeah it
also probably red arrow but you know I
think it's probably some fan service
great i mean it would be a little corny
you know if you got a psychic and called
him speedy yeah don't I didn't have a
problem with that you know yes guy like
of course you have the whole drama with
his mom and you know step dad and the
flashers we're still learning about this
mystery don't know what's going on just
keep going back to the island all which
it most cases is kind of like my
favorite part of the show especially
like you know just seeing death stroke
or anything how that relationship is
gonna play out and stuff I mean I'm
really excited so you gotta feel me a
little bit like I can I we both three
combos mike has a definitely lot more
history on on the subject than I do so
now that's because he always a bad Gary
sometimes a good guy I've seen antihero
um as far as I'm concerned he's always
bad he's always better yeah but that's
just the way I like I'm just kind of
like the the villain burr he's like the
ruling Batman right like this is what
Batman would be like he had um Billy
wintergreen yeah just kind of like his
Alfred which you know was on the show in
season one but it was different but it
was good you know I enjoyed it so that's
basically how that works and I think
that's so cool now granted he's a little
bit younger now sure you know and he
doesn't bit of a badass but it seems
like he's trying to work with Oliver so
didn't be interesting to see that how
that plays out eventually he's gotta be
bad guy that's how I want my distro oh
god I mean and I like the two we do know
that um man do banette who you know the
fans of you know think here we know we
love Spartacus I was yeah we got to
interview him the comic con ESO he seems
like a great guy and we're so he signed
on for season two it's we're gonna see a
lot of them I hope and I guess maybe we
can start look are blending summer this
year maybe start moving into a little
bit of the season 2 discussion and the
trailer everything I hope that maybe
we'll get a chance to see him off the
island I don't know if he's ever gonna
be there just in flashbacks or we can
see him coming into you know the city it
would be nice based on what I saw in the
trailer it seems like there's all
a lot going on yeah so I'd imagine green
Deathstroke you know two off the island
right now might be too much but who
knows I mean I would last thing I want
them to do is to rush all that because I
think that's so much fun like the
flashbacks and everything I would really
like them to focus i guess more on just
fleshing that out you know cuz i mean i
feel like we really haven't seen just
what made oliver who he is today not yet
you seem like the early you know his
early transition but like you know it
still has a ways to go so i'd like to
see more of that but um you know
definite like in the trailer like you
see a little bit more roy harper and
that's not really looking forward to
yeah you know maybe I Marci I'd go that
I got a little time ago 2010 yeah not
too much but uh wait to see more of them
yeah and play a larger role and because
he is you know Oliver Queen they's gonna
have some ladies of course Bruce Wayne
James Bond all remain billionaire yet
all these guys you know so uh summer
glau was gonna be joining the show yeah
summer glau Firefly you know Sarah
Connor Chronicles we can say that three
times fast you know that escape look oh
holy that way I'll stay out of the cave
yeah but she's gone to the show I love
summer glau so it was a character said
it sounds like a that she's playing yeah
Isabel rochev see again I I didn't
really grow up reading Green Arrow so I
don't know too much about her past other
than you know she could be a potential
love interest movie but I'm assuming it
was gonna happen then you know I believe
maybe she might play a factor as far as
like Oliver right you know his company
and everything is concerned so you know
that could be fun right of course we
have Felicity still I love her is not
you know the Oscars computer girl on you
know that's not screen right now so big
a role bigger role yeah so I mean I
think this season's gonna be interesting
for sin the trailer if you've seen her
from the comic con trailer we do get a
snapshot of Black Canary yes I'm sorry
good so excited universe is expanding of
course we can always hope maybe maybe
maybe we can least see Bruce if I mean
Oliver Queen's a billionaire he's going
to meetings new can at least see him
Bruce in a suit uh you know I know this
have Bruce Wayne pop up on I watched
smallville for ten years waiting and
overnight I see Bruce at some point and
never gonna happen so we're probably
gonna hold that's a little bit too far
and I guess the other news you want to
go into is not something else I was
released from comic-con is news about
the flash oh yeah I don't believe
they've announced which flash is going
to beer i'm going to assume
because geoff johns wrote an episode or
so yeah she's in one I worked for DC
comics you know writer on the bigger
writers that he is more of a fan of
Barry yeah yeah he is a berry guy hello
I would assume is probably gonna be
berry speculate I mean I love I love
wall e as well and I know small head
Bart you know and but um yeah I'd love
to do you know see some berry and see
how that works on really curious to see
how that's gonna play out though so it
was great we're gonna get I think a
little bit of an arc with him i'm gonna
guess it's because there's nothing the
trailer to indicate this is probably mid
way later on in the season yeah i'm just
gonna spin off into his own show which i
would assume would air sometimes I
cousin 14c that's been maybe a couple
couple episodes right you know it's also
just going into probably one of Oliver's
most significant love interest is to I
keep my lovin just cuz they're so
popular popular the show is Laurel yeah
you know with some of the drama that
happened at the end of season 1 i'm
trying not to spoil no no we're talking
about a lot of subtracting the season
one here so that's why i'm kind of
avoiding the season one finale stuff so
but like Laurel now you know her role
might be expanding yeah I hope so I mean
I think it's some to be expected and I'm
certainly excited to see like the
changes that are going to be made I mean
you figure with you know bringing a
comic book character to TV or film
they're gonna be some changes yeah right
and so you know anyone that's you know
that read reads comics knows about
Laurel oh yeah you know and she doesn't
quite she's not quite the little that I
expected but that's cool though cuz i'm
assuming they're gonna build up to
something right you know i mean there
were a few you know glimpses of what she
could do in season one you know a little
fighting here and there and snow some
I'm certainly excited to see how they're
gonna build up on that and eventually
explain just how you know she is who she
is right and just further ongoing
looking into predictions for the next
season maybe future seasons show the
show's doing really well the show is
kind of as a gritty feel as trying to
stay up in the real world Merlin our
Merlin um arrow has a lot of you know
has a lot of supernatural stuff yeah a
few nitrogen is one of his boys I mean
hey Jason blowing all those guys a
supernatural like but it seems like
they're gonna kind of shy away from that
it's yeah that I can do it's gonna work
problems Smallville it's like you could
only really do so much in a show with
the smart budget right you know that's
why they kind of waited to do darkside
season 10 and even that was just kind of
you know whatever yeah
so I would imagine they're probably
gonna stick with the gritty real feel
like Batman yeah you know what I mean
this hard I mean it's nice it's hard to
sell show on CW the people you're
friends with a goatee watch a bunch of
show then you see dead people think
Nevel 210 Vampire Diaries which we love
here natural supernatural you only shows
it actually good they have huge like
cult followings but it's like I think
because in on the major networks on AMC
HBO like people are like oh it's a CW
that's teeny stuff and I'm like no
arrows it's better than a crime show
I've been like nyp I'm sorry that's too
much uh learned like a CIS whatever
whatever season you know 50 yeah I mean
I think it's better than that I'm always
talking people I turned when my buddies
onto the show not typically into stuff
like that but I was like I swear to you
it's not cheesy it's actually good right
it's like check it out it's good so
those are some of our thoughts we have
on season one as well as the trailer
some of the footage again we try to
avoid few the spoiler so if you need to
catch up please catch up because i
believe it's october ninth yes the CW
would premiering season 2 which taglines
city of heroes cydia heroes come on
justice let's go see wait do it right
it's gonna be fun dude trailer looks
amazing if you haven't seen it go
youtube it right now right check it out
so thanks for joining us some as always
you can find more of our videos right
here on the YouTube channel think hero
pro we're also on Twitter i'm at griffin
d where can we find you yeah at mr.
michael alexis i did also come check us
out on our website at thank yo calm but
facebook page as well and that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans
you